[Music]
the iPhone 5 is available in Apple
stores this Friday but people who
pre-ordered it online are going to have
to wait two to three more weeks for
their iPhones to ship yeah and this is
news is really bumming people out a lot
of unhappy Apple fans anyway not to
worry Apple has prepared this guide to
help people get through the wait no we
here at Apple understand your
frustration at having to wait an extra
two or three weeks for your new iPhone 5
to ship no person should have to
experience that kind of torment but we
do have suggestions as to how you can
pass the time during that agonizing wait
wait quietly wait quietly some more
sleep eat eat in the background even the
foreground see how long you can dribble
a basketball see how long you cannot
dribble a basketball hurl insult to your
iPhone 4s is so sick of you all of a
sudden the practice taking compliments
on your iPhone 5 thank you
beat yourself at chess dammit well
practice your dinosaur
hands pretend your couch is a
rollercoaster pretend your couch is a
broken rollercoaster where are we moving
run away from nothing pretend your feet
are making out start p90x No
rehearse for a different comedy bit oh
my god Bob Saget make something and
before you know it it would be time to
order the iPhone 6
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]